[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le débrief du
doc dans ce numéro on va s'intéresser
aux documentaires rt toxicité ou comment
une ville ghanéenne abrite une des plus
grandes décharges électronique de la
planète à ciel ouvert sans aucune
réglementation les centaines de milliers
de tonnes de déchets déversés chaque
année qu'on y trouve viennent de loin de
pays dits développés ceux qui
travaillent parfois très ou trop jeunes
le font péril de leur vie la gestion des
déchets en afrique leur revalorisation
une problématique très difficile à
résoudre
on en parle avec une spécialiste de la
question qui s'est longuement documenté
sur le sujet géographe enseignante
chercheuse à l'université du mans et au
laboratoire cnrs réseau adeline pierrât
bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur arte
france alors comment avez vous trouvé ce
documentaire bonjour merci pour
l'invitation
ce documentaire il faire inscrire dans
une série de films produits depuis une
dizaine d'années soulevant les problèmes
posés par ces méga décharge que l'on
trouve dans les pays dans les pays de
l'est et en particulier dans les
métropoles d'afrique alors toxicité en 6
particulièrement sur une dimension la
dangerosité de ces bombes à retardement
pour la santé des travailleurs mais
également pour les populations qui
vivent à proximité de ces sites du fait
des concentrations de plomb et d'arsenic
il est très fidèle à ce qu'on peut
observer
lorsque l'on fait du terrain mais
au-delà de ce titre en fait bien
d'autres aspects sont révélés dans le
film
l'ambivalence de la décharge entre
nuisances et ressources les jeux
d'acteurs la place d'akbou banshee dans
la ville d'accra l'informalité des
activités et puis la mondialisation des
flux de déchets autant d'aspects que je
suis ravi de discuter avec alors pour
contextualiser on va poser le décor un
je vous laisse découvrir le premier
extrait regarder
c'est quoi regarde c'est du cuivre grâce
à ces de l'aluminium
on peut le prendre aussi à lomé
[Musique]
des manuels à kandy riquet a passé toute
son enfance à la déchetterie il n'est
jamais allé à l'école et ne peut aller
nulle part ailleurs
ce travail est son seul moyen de
subsistance
maintenant chez 14 ans mon père m'a
amené ici et les partis juste après il
m'a laissé tout seul travail il m'a dit
qu'il allait revenir un jour et me
ramener dans ma ville natale
selon les lois guinéennes
emmanuel n'a pas le droit de travailler
avant de sa majorité mais personne ne
sont plus ici de jeunes enfants
travaillent tôt si certains n'ont pas de
parents la fois certains ont perdu leur
père ou leur mère
1 certains ont encore lambert 2 il y en
a aussi qui viennent travailler ici le
matin et vont ensuite à l'école certains
n'y vont pas du tout d'autres viennent
ici le matin récupère le faire le vendre
contre de petites pièces puis vont en
cours alors c'est cruel on vient d'en
entendre le jeune emmanuel il a 14 ans
il n'a jamais été à l'école
malheureusement il est loin d'être le
seul en fonte à travailler dans de
telles conditions
oui alors il ya plusieurs aspects qu'on
peut soulever après avoir visionné cet
extrait la première chose c'est que l'on
voit
l'accumulation vraiment d'énormes
quantités de déchets en cela depuis
trois voire quatre décennies
elle incarne vraiment un modèle un
modèle de gestion linéaire des déchets
en produits on consomme et puis en jette
et on accumule l'extrait à travers
l'exemple de ses enfants qui pratiquent
la fouille pour survivre et bien
illustre un autre aspect c'est vraiment
la valorisation de ces déchets qui
constitue vraiment une source de revenus
très importante pour des populations
parfois très jeunes on retrouve
effectivement énormément d'enfants sur
sur les sites de décharge qui viennent
parfois aussi des régions rurales et
pour qui en fait la décharge constitue
un point d'entrée dans la ville un point
d'entrée dans la ville on va retrouver
peut-être des parents des amis des
cousins un réseau de relations de
personnes en provenance de la même
région du même village parfois et qui
vont finalement nous aider aussi
eh bien à survivre au delà de l'aspect
pratique de la fouille à aider dans les
décharges que j'ai pu sur lesquels j'ai
pu enquêter
les enfants étaient quand même souvent
scolarisés
au moins une partie de la journée
parfois quelques jours par semaine et
c'est pas rare en fait que l'on que que
l'on voit des écoles alors peut-être
parfois un peu de bric et de broc mais
ce secret et être créés spécialement
pour les enfants de la décharge
c'était le cas en ethiopie c'est le cas
aussi à madagascar avant de parler de la
gestion des déchets locaux on va
s'attarder un petit peu sur cette
décharge au ghana particulièrement des
ordinateurs des téléphones venus de loin
d'occident parfois en toute illégalité
comment est ce possible
effectivement un blog lochies
spécialisée dans une filière la filière
des d3 les déchets d'équipements
électroniques et électriques qui sont
des déchets en très très forte
augmentation sur le continent africain
il ya quelques années on voyait plus
classiquement des des récupérateurs
trier les tissus les fripes les
plastiques
mais depuis dix ans eh bien on a une
très forte augmentation de produits en
provenance des pays du nord d'europe en
particulier pour ce qui est de l'afrique
de l'ouest mais parfois également aussi
de chine ou d'inde d'asie
on va dire et ces déchets arrivent
effectivement en toute illégalité
alors il ya des stratégies qui sont
mises en place le documentaire le montre
assez bien envoyer des appareils qui
fonctionnent encore un peu que l'on met
devant devant les portes du conteneur et
puis au fond du conteneur on a plutôt et
bien des matières qui sont non
transformable non récupérables pas
réparable et donc des déchets il ya des
conventions pourtant qu'il existe depuis
depuis plusieurs plusieurs décennies la
convention de bâle et la convention de
bamako qui sont censés réduire la
circulation de ces déchets dangereux et
en particulier qui vise à éviter le
transfert de ces déchets des pays du
nord
vers les pays du sud et vers l'afrique
en particulier et notamment vers les
villes portuaires
alors les desserts jeu tentaculaire à
l'image de celle d'accra vous en avez
visité plusieurs vous avez enquêté addis
abeba antananarive dakar quel est le
sentiment que vous avez ressenti en
voyant cela ce documentaire m'a vraiment
replonger en fait dans des premiers
terrains de recherche qui sont déjà
assez anciens les premiers ont été
réalisés en 2006 2007
bien sûr c'est un contexte ce sont des
contacts de recherche qui se fondra dans
une grande pauvreté dans une grande
précarité
évidemment beaucoup d'empathie quand on
travaille quand on enquête auprès de ces
personnes
ces enquêtes elles ont été très longues
il m'a fallu plusieurs mois pour réussir
à pouvoir m'entretenir obtenir des
données et fiable à pouvoir être en
immersion dans ces univers qui sont
quand même extrêmement dur extrêmement
violent on le voit également aussi à la
fin du documentaire et c'est finalement
la confiance à travers l'ingéniosité la
compréhension vraiment de ce système
c'est ça qui m'a permis finalement de
pouvoir être accepté par les
récupérateurs et pouvoir produire les
données que que j'ai réussi à obtenir
sur plusieurs sites à chaque fois en
employant des méthodes d'un petit peu
différente parce que chaque site de
décharge et particulier en afrique on a
un essor démographique très important
une urbanisation donc forcément encore
et encore plus de déchets finalement
elle la gestion des détritus
est-ce que c'est pas un peu nouveau pour
le continent africain
si vous avez tout à fait raison si on
essaie de contextualiser un petit peu
les prévisions que l'on peut avoir
alors c'est tiré d'un rapport de la
banque mondiale qui s'appelle the water
waste qui qui estime que la production
déchets va être multiplié par 3 en
afrique d'ici à 2050
alors pour deux raisons
la production par jour et par habitant
qui est très faible par rapport au reste
du monde actuellement on est à moins de
500 grammes pour lui par jour et par
habitant en afrique
elle augmente mais surtout la population
sur le continent africain augmente
également s'associe à ses deux premières
variable et bien le le changement des
pratiques de consommation en afrique et
donc effectivement s'attend à avoir à
traiter des quantités spectaculaire
c'est ces prochaines années
or les systèmes de gestion sont toujours
des failles liens et les ces sites de
décharge qui existe depuis 30 parfois 40
ans sont complètement saturé donc une ba
il faut réfléchir à des solutions a fait
urgemment alors la gestion des déchets
en africains que ce soit une compétence
publics ou privés à quel point la
corruption empêche cette filière d'être
efficace sans forcément parler de
corruption
il faut vraiment imaginé deux systèmes
en parallèle un système qui vise
vraiment à gérer les déchets à les
sortir de la ville et à aller les
traiter disons à l'extérieur de l'espace
urbain
et puis un autre système parallèle très
imbriqué 1 les deux et parallèle et en
même temps il ya de forts liens
l'autre système c'est celui de la
récupération informel de la valorisation
des déchets et c'est vraiment ce qu'on
voit sur ces sites de décharge
c'est le point de rencontre de ces deux
systèmes est donc en fait ce sont des
plutôt des solutions hybrides qu'il
s'agit d'essayer de réfléchir de
proposer pour tenir compte de ses
activités de valorisation qui sont très
positives même si elles sont mal encadré
même si elle se déroule dans des
conditions désastreuses on le voit très
bien dans le documentaire mais qui
néanmoins sont une réponse forte à mieux
valoriser les déchets mieux les recycler
en afrique est passé un mode de gestion
on appelle cycliques c'est-à-dire faire
en sorte que la plupart des déchets et
une seconde vie pour répondre à ce
problème de la de la saturation des
sites de décharge année
pierre je vous retrouve tout de suite
c'est l'heure de marquer une courte
pause on se retrouve sur l'attrait
france dans quelques instants est de
retour sur rt france on continue de
parler du documentaire toxicité avec la
géographe adeline pire à vous êtes
toujours avec nous a dit nokia collecte
traitement recyclage ans pour
schématiser c'est un peu sa main la
gestion des déchets lors de la première
étape
déjà en afrique qu'est ce qui coince
alors ce qui coince c'est comme dans
d'autres villes du sud
on se trouve dans une configuration où
la vie il fonctionne un peu à deux
vitesses on va avoir une ville centrale
des quartiers centraux plutôt soignée et
dans lesquels on va essayer de mettre en
place des systèmes de gestion efficaces
quitte à passer des contrats très
coûteux avec des entreprises privées
et puis on va avoir d'autres quartiers
alors c'est souvent des quartiers
périphériques mais c'est pas de
systématique qui ne vont pas être
desservis par des voies saleté les rues
elles vont être soit pierreuse soit
sableux c'est le cas des villes
sahélienne et donc les quartiers sont
très difficiles d'accès et finalement
est bien la collecte repose plutôt sur
un système où les habitants vont devoir
prendre leurs poubelles et allait les
déposer jusqu'à ce qu'on appelle des
points d'apports volontaires qui sont
parfois situées à plusieurs centaines de
mètres voire un ou deux kilomètres de
ces points de collecte officielle et
donc et bien se met en place en
particulier dans ces quartiers d'autres
systèmes de gestion des déchets avec des
personnes identifiées clairement qu'on
appelle des grossistes qui vont eux
récupérer également les déchets en vue
de les trier et les transformer en fait
ils envoient ces matières vers d'autres
circuits de traitement et de
valorisation qui échappent du coup au
système de gestion formelle qui est mis
en place par les municipalités
principalement alors donc la dernière
étape c'est donc la valorisation des
déchets mais finalement ces jeunes
travailleurs c'est désert ce qu'elles
font recycler ray
qui paierait puis d'en transformer assez
d'aptitudes oui c'était un métier ancien
et etc ces jeunes trouvent assez
rapidement alors général il pratique la
fouille pendant quelques quelques mois
et puis ensuite il se forme à d'autres
métiers fouillé mais également ensuite
triés par fouara il identifie aussi
d'autres des débouchés clairement des
grossistes des personnes qui vont être
intéressés par par ces matières et ces
jeunes et bien acquiert en fait des
compétences qui leur donne l'occasion
d'avoir un vrai métier même si au départ
où il est quand même plutôt dans une
situation de survie
c'est le cas du petit garçon qui est qui
interrogé et dont on n'a pas pu écouter
tout à l'heure dans le premier extrait
oui c'est vrai que tous ces jeunes en
jeunes aux plus âgés viennent du secteur
informel
partons du constat qu on arrive un peu à
fermer c'est des charges
tous ces gens là qui vivent de ça parce
qu'on a vu un bien évidemment il y en a
qui nourrissent leur famille avec ça il
faudra bien leur trouver un nouvel
emploi
comment on les intègre dans le secteur
formel alors effectivement un abord de
la question des solutions qui sont
proposées pour pour essayer de résoudre
le problème de saturation de ses sites
dans nombre de grandes villes d'afrique
ce qui se passe c'est qu'on envisage
alors de manière parfois très compliqué
on envisage de fermer ses sites de
décharge pour construire encore plus
loin à l'extérieur de la ville des
centres d'enfouissement technique des
sites qui vont être cette fois-ci
sécurisé qui vont être équipés d'un
système de récupération de ce qu'on
appelle des lixiviats ou du jus de
déchets qui dans les sites décharges non
contrôlées s'infiltre dans le sol on va
sécuriser les sites et ces sites là et
bien en longtemps été présenté comme la
solution de
de là près des charges mais en fait
plusieurs problèmes se posent
d'abord ce sont des installations qui
sont très coûteuses et qui demande à ce
que et bien les déchets arrivent
régulièrement et en grande quantité or
étant donné les problèmes de gestion en
amont que l'on vient de mentionner et
bien très souvent les déchets ont
beaucoup de mal à arriver jusqu'à ses
centres d'enfouissement technique donc
certains récupérateurs et bien se voient
proposer en fait un travail sur les
sites d'enfouissement technique ils sont
largement majoritaires les autres en
fait souvent on continue à pratiquer la
valorisation puisque les déchets sont
partout donc en fait même si on
travaille plus sur le site de décharge
on aura toujours d'autres points de
dépôt on aura toujours la possibilité de
travailler dans la filière déchets même
si ça se fait pas sur le site donc le
gros enjeu c'est d'accompagner ce
secteur-là d'accompagner à la
professionnalisation à la reconnaissance
de ses activités de valorisation des
déchets et certains acteurs certaines
ong le font déjà très bien même si c'est
extrêmement compliqué on a la
reconnaissance et la régularisation de
ce secteur
alors vous en parliez tout à l'heure un
de ses points des problèmes de ces
décharges c'est bien évidemment la
toxicité en efface pour la santé des
travailleurs
regardez cet extrait
ils placent brûler toutes sortes et de
plastique est toxique on trouve ici un
mélange d'éléments parmi les plus
toxiques au monde et qui sont rejetées
dans l'air ce combiné est ce mélange est
très dangereux il agi très vite dans
l'organisme il raccourcit votre vie bien
plus que si vous ne viviez la mort aura
tous les jours victor schepper
gestionnaires de déchets est arrivé au
ghana d'allemagne travailler avec les
déchets ici promettait des bénéfices
importants plus élevé qu'en europe
occidentale
en fait j'ai rejoint cette activité de
traitement des déchets pour produire du
compost car les déchets au ghana qui
contiennent plus de matière organique
que ceux d'europe
cela fait 40 ans que je vis ici et je
peux dire que la situation ne s'est pas
améliorée c'est vraiment dramatique
on a assez de loi le problème n'est pas
là des lois sur l'environnement tout ça
mais personne ne fait en sorte qu'elle
soit respectée
chacun fait ce qu'il veut c'est ça le
problème
en fin de compte tout le monde ici est
concerné regarder tout ça nous nous
vivons nous allons nous mangeons c'est
très mauvais pour nous absolument
regarder ces êtres humains qui vivent
ici chaque jour ça s'étend chaque jour
ça c'est en ça s'étend les jeunes vivent
ici
oui ce n'est pas à nous qu'on pense mais
à nos enfants mais il faut que vous
pensiez à vous car vous aussi vous avez
tombé malade et si ça arrive vous ne
pourrez plus vous occuper des enfants
donc c'est vraiment très sérieux c'est
pourquoi nous les avons fait venir pour
exercer une pression au niveau
international il faut que vous nous
aidiez ce n'est pas bien le sort de ces
travailleurs exposés un quotidiennement
à de la fumée toxique qui s'en soucie
qui s'en soucie il ya les centres de
santé et les structures qui participent
à leur création dans les décharges que
j'ai pu visiter sur lesquels j'ai pu
enquêter systématiquement on avait un
système de santé qui était accolé au
site
c'était le cas à dakar qui existe un
centre de santé qui existe depuis très
longtemps
voisin de la décharge de mbeubeuss et
qui a constaté effectivement et bien des
problèmes de santé parfois très graves
chez les travailleurs parfois aussi un
petit peu plus simplement mais mais mais
mais ce sont des choses qui arrivent
quotidiennement des coupures des
blessures graves liés et liés à la
pratique de la fouille sans sans
équipements de protection individuelle
sans gants sans masque sans chaussures
adaptées à la cette activité donc des
centres de santé quand même toujours
assez assez présents à proximité de ces
sites
la fumée est néfaste pour les personnes
travaillant dans la décharge on vient de
le voir mais ça va bien au delà regarder
[Musique]
il y a deux sites ac bourthes cauchy le
premier est le plus grand marché de
fruits d'afrique de l'ouest et le
deuxième est le plus grand centre de
contamination de la planète et pas
seulement d'afrique de l'ouest et il n'y
a qu'une rue entre les deux cela
signifie donc qu'on accepte le fait que
quand les gamins brûle toutes ces
ordures de plastique la fumée fini par
faire un dépôt sur la nourriture en
compétition
le marché des oignons et tout sa vie en
effet les gens qui achètent ici vous
vous rendez compte
le bétail élevé sur place ils vont tuer
les bêtes et cuisiner la viande les gens
qu'on a mangé
donc ça n'affecte pas seulement ceux qui
sont ici mais ça se propage au reste de
la ville d'akron à jean pierre a
finalement on vers le voir c'est tout le
pays qui est contaminée oui il ya deux
aspects à aborder après cet extrait le
premier c'est que ces décharges
il n'ya 30 40 ans elle était située à
l'extérieur de la ville
et puis ces villes ont considérablement
grossi elles se sont beaucoup pétales et
est du coup la plupart des décharges se
retrouvent soit vraiment aux portes de
la ville soit carrément dans la ville
c'était le cas de la décharge d'addis
abeba donc finalement c'est ces lieux de
décharge se retrouve à être vraiment des
hauts lieux dans la ville des hauts
lieux pour travailler des hauts lieux
pour vendre des reports proposer des
petits services à ses très nombreux
travailleurs des déchets selon c'est
plus c'est plutôt des milliers que des
centaines de travailleurs qui sont
occupés à travailler dans les déchets la
deuxième chose c'est avant tout
également un grand marché un grand
marché des déchets un grand marché des
matières donc a donc le chien on est
plutôt sur une spécialisation des d3e
mais dans d'autres décharges on a un peu
toutes les filières et c'est donc pas
très surprenant de voir également
d'autres types de marchés plus classique
des marchés qui rassemble des produits
vivriers marchands ou d'autres ou tout
simplement les produits de seconde main
donc ils sont issus de la valorisation
des déchets autant de marmites et
ustensiles de cuisine qui sont produits
à tra partir des déchets de la
récupération et on se retrouve à avoir
dans ces villes et bien des très grands
espaces avec différents marchés clés qui
sont les voisins qui sont accolés c'est
le cas à dannemarie c'est le cas à dakar
c'était dans une certaine mesure le cas
à addis abeba
admin pire à merci d'avoir été avec nous
je rappelle que vous êtes géographe
enseignante chercheuse à l'université du
mans et au laboratoire cnrs réseau vous
avez visité enquêter dans des décharges
sur le continent africain
merci à vous d'avoir été avec merci à
vous également de nous avoir été fidèle
et d'avoir suivi cette émission à très
bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]